we're going to begin this hour though
with acclaimed journalist that's Maria
ressa she's recipient of the Nobel Peace
Prize you go Maria she was awarded the
Nobel a year ago for her work covering
the Philippine government's violent
anti-drug Campaign which led to a
massive protest around the country Russo
became a target of then Phil Philippines
president Rodrigo duterte for six years
she has defended herself against
criminal charges including alleged cyber
libel for her website's reporting she
faces decades in prison still still but
continues to return to the Philippines
to fight the charges Russ's new book is
is called how to stand up to a dictator
the fight for our future so it's a
memoir of her early life in her career
and a call to battle against the lies in
propaganda spread on social media and
first on CBS mornings we are so excited
and so happy to tell you that Maria
Russa is at our table it is such a
pleasure and an honor to meet you in
person so wonderful you are such a
badass I have such admiration for you
oh I'm not being kind of girl says that
I'm speaking the truth Ruth because you
say you don't really know who you are
until you are forced to fight you said
you don't know if you have the stomach
to fight in order to change a culture
they will fight back but you have to
have the stomach and this is the thing
that got me about you Maria because I
think it's important to set the table
who you are you say lies with anger and
hate spread faster than facts without
facts there's no truth without truth
there's no trust there's no shared
reality democracy is death by a Thousand
Cuts and you put the blame squarely in
part on Facebook of which you were a big
proponent of in the beginning what
happened I mean there's so much there so
first of all those three sentences
without facts you can't have truth
without truth you can't have trust that
I felt like Sisyphus and Cassandra
combined because I've been saying those
three senses over and over since 2016.
um and with Facebook the company that is
now 10 years old really started on
Facebook I was the true lowest of True
Believers I had hoped for a country like
the Philippines that this technology
could actually help jump start
development you know if you've been a
journalist for a really long time you
know corruption is the problem right but
how do you expect the top to do it all
of a sudden there was this probably
maybe that we could build institutions
bottom up right so deeply disappointed
when when this business model but you
said they knowingly spread lies that's
what you're saying what do you mean it
is by Design Gail what do you mean so
MIT came out with a study 2018 that said
that lies spread at least six times
faster on social media you're not just
talking Facebook but I zoomed in on
Facebook in the Philippines because a
hundred percent of Filipinos on the
internet are on Facebook Facebook is our
internet we're kind of like your petri
dish right Cambridge analytica
whistleblower called us said that they
tested tactics of mass manipulation and
if it worked in our country then they
ported it to you so we were the guinea
pigs you were the targets but you
brought into their attention that's the
thing you brought it to their attention
so the lies spread six times faster on
social media why doesn't the truth catch
up right because one theory is that you
know Free Speech the answer is just more
speech and eventually the best and
truest answers win Brenda said that in
1927 before the age of exponential lies
before the age of social media right now
it's almost like you know if you think
about a war for our individual
consciences right the devil and the
angel the angel tells you do the right
thing the devil tells you you know do it
do it do it well what social media did
is it gagged the angel and kicked it off
your shoulder and it gave the devil
bigger voice directly into your nervous
system social media is a behavior
modification system the data shows it
and we are experimented on like Pavlov
Stones changing our Behavior right so
this is evidence-based if you look
there's several books and research now
that has come out that shows the impact
how our emotions are manipulated
insidiously to change the way we think
Thinking Fast thinking slow they come in
thinking slow they Sorry Thinking Fast
and then they change your world view
which leads to things like violence on
January 6 2021 and then it leads to the
vote because if you don't have integrity
of facts you do not have integrity of
Elections yeah there's some programming
that happens when it comes to us and how
we interact with social media for sure
and we don't recognize that we are being
programmed simultaneously I would say
war war like information operations
first talk about information Warfare
with Russia and Ukraine but for
Americans where you have the data
released in a thousand page Mueller
report that no one really pays attention
to yeah that data shows that you were
targeted things like identity politics
black lives matter didn't matter which
side they weren't trying to push aside
they hit both sides right when you say a
lie a million times it becomes a fact do
you think Facebook could fix itself it
could have right and the longer it takes
they could have it you mean do you think
it's too late so think about
um there's a Yuri andropov the former
KGB chairman said this which which stuck
with me this information is Like Cocaine
you take it once or twice you're okay
but if you take it all the time you're a
changed person so from 2016 to 2022
right think about that as like a drug
addiction and we are slowly we're
physically this is part of the death by
a Thousand Cuts in the Philippines I was
thinking about it like you know if you
get a paper cut you'll give in you look
away it's only a paper cup but you're
bleeding out and you don't know how weak
you are and then democracy is weak not
just here although where you go we all
go but globally yeah Maria you say you
will not become a monster to fight a
monster and I say this with all respect
I don't know how you were still alive
your life is constantly threatened you
were constantly in Peril you tell the
story in the book where you're sitting
on the plane get at the airport getting
ready to go back to the Philippines and
you're told the minute you land you will
be arrested you will be illegally
detained indefinitely and before I turn
the page I said please don't go please
don't go and you get on the friggin
plane and you still continue to do that
you continue to fight you say you will
always fight why
because what happens next against
misinformation
disinformation I that's one of the
things it's not misinformation it's
disinformation it is information
operations what happens to me depends on
what I do now we have to get back agency
right for every American for every
person on social media where is the line
between your will and the way the
platforms manipulate you or the way even
anyone who wants power can micro Target
you right and for me it's whether I go
to jail
if I give up of course I will but Maria
how do you fight back I've struggled
with this when people don't believe the
facts don't believe the video don't
believe what they're seeing how do you
fight back against that
in big term in the long term right it's
always education legislation is the
medium term because frankly why is there
not a Better Business Bureau for our
minds and emotions right why are laws
not put in place for for genetic
research like crispr technology where we
can customize a baby
Western Nations America put guard rails
in place laws this one's so Insidious
we're left on our own
you know that online violence is real
world violence and impunity online is
impunity offline in the short term it is
just us it's hand-to-hand combat right
and right if you have kids I worry about
the Next Generation I'm hopeful but I
also worry yes I yeah she is not
standing down and by the way that you
run the Nobel Peace Prize I think that
gets a little paragraph compared to what
happens in the book congratulations so
happy to have you thank you for joining
us your work is so important you are so
brave thank you how to stand up to a
dictator is the name of her book it's on
sale tomorrow wherever you like to buy
your books